gentlemen ladies what if Superman had
decided to fly down rip off the roof of
the White House
grab the president right out of the Oval
Office who would have stopped him I want
to build a team with some very bad
people who I think can do some good
y'all Joker's must be crazy
this is the deal you just pay me you die
try to skate you die
no boyfriend you irritate or vex me I'm
known to be quite vexing I'm just for
warning you you die they get caught we
throw them under the bus what a ride
let's play mutt get something better
I love this guy
not good don't forget with the bad guys
are you sweet-talking me all of that
chit chats gonna get charged with a whip
ride
we'll do you wanna see songul y'all
wanna see stuff yes I want to see stuff
I was just trying to get you there
no hard feelings all right we good
what you having beer whiskey what am i
12
how are you hot stuff water that's a
good idea I'll play this is just fantasy
caught in a landslide no escape from
reality
I want our simple task force of the most
dangerous people on the planet
they're bad guys worst of the worst
was this a cheerleading trial
ah hi boys
good shot guy shoots people he's
crocodile he eats people burns people
you're possessed by twitch she's just
crazy
oh is that I should kill everyone and
escape sorry
the voices I'm kidding that's not what
they really said this is the deal you're
going something with our very bad do
something though gets killed so save the
world
I can't wait to show you my toys let's
do something fun
on me
you
seriously the hell's wrong with you
people
you're bad guys it's what we do
let's check in some work but I finally
have them the worst of the worst
we're let's just say I put them in a
hole - away the hole there's rumors
Amanda that some of them have abilities
oh yeah I have seen things maybe
Superman was some kind of beacon for
them to creep back from the shadows
I want to assemble a task force of the
most dangerous people on the planet who
I think can do some good they're bad
guys exactly and if anything goes wrong
we blame them we have built-in
deniability what makes you think you can
control because getting people to act
against their own self-interest is what
I do follow
I use the devil
all you need to know is you work for me
so that's it huh we're the passes with
some kind of Suicide Squad
so save the world
Ares
we got insurance
now they say about the crazy ones huh oh
I'm not gonna kill ya
I'm just gonna hurt you really really
bad hello young headshot - she's lighter
there's some hope of you f the slaughter
never burned lighter you'll be